-We've met on this show.
-We did.
-Not too long ago.
We played musical beers.
-Right.
-Yeah.
What else do you remember
about that?
-We got very close, you and I.
We did.
-Yeah. We kind of did.
I have a --
-We made out.
-We -- No, we didn't.
No.
-It was close.
-Well, let me show you.
Here's a clip of us playing
musical beers on our show.
Take a look at this.
-Oh, [bleep]!
[ Laughter ]
[Bleep]
-Spin it back! Spin it back!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We gotta drink that, baby.
I'll gladly lose.
[ Crowd chanting "Drink" ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God. Yes!
-The commitment.
We had to.
-It was good.
It was for the audience.
Yeah. Had to show you.
Hey. Everyone's welcome here.
-I appreciate it.
-Gosh, that was bizarre
to watch that back.
-No, it was -- it was --
Here's what happened.
I mean, I was before --
Right before I came on,
you know, my manager, my great
manager, Emily Gerson Saines,
was backstage, and the thing
she said to me was, like,
"Whatever you do,
do not be the first one out."
She was like -- And I was like,
"Why are you doing this
to me right now?"
She was like, "Just don't lose.
Don't be the first one out."
So I came in, you know, strong.
-[ Laughs ]
-A little too strong.
-Yeah, a little too strong.
No, it was perfect.
We're happy to you have back.
-Thank you.
You went on to -- Congrats
on "Avengers: Endgame."
This movie is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
$1.4 billion it's made so far.
Wow.
-Yeah.
Does it change -- Does your life
change completely?
-Well, it has --
You know, for me, I mean,
it's been ten years,
so it's a little bit nostalgic,
but it's only been since last
year and "Infinity War"
that, like, I've sort of been
feeling like I'm in this
Fight Club that I don't
really know about.
I was on a plane one time,
and the stewardess came
and gave me this piece of paper
and walked away,
and I opened it,
and it said "Wakanda Forever."
And then I looked, after, down
the hall, and she just went...
-Wow! Wow!
-I was like, "Just get us home."
[ Laughter ]
But it's very humbling,
for sure, just to be included.
I mean, the movie is insane.
-It's great. You're history.
Absolutely.
But when you're filming
the scenes, do you know
what you're even remotely doing
or what lines you're saying?
-We did not.
For this one, we didn't.
I mean, everything I filmed,
I found out on the day.
You can kind of tell, like,
by my expression.
I just --
I hide the confusion well.
Under a "Zoolander" look.
But, no, we didn't know.
-Like when you were in there
with all of your co-stars,
did you know that they were
going to be there that day?
-No. I was told
there was a wedding.
You know, that there was
a wedding that we were filming.
And I was like,
"Who's getting married?"
But everybody
was dressed very formal,
and, you know,
I was looking around,
and then two people
weren't there,
so I guess that was
the bride and the groom.
But that's what it was.
It was a wedding.
You saw the movie, right?
-Yeah, of course, it was.
-That's what it was.
-Yes, of course. Oh, yeah.
Sebastian, absolutely, it was.
I'll never get you in trouble.
Yeah, of course.
But now I got to say --
I just heard this, and I hope
that the rumor is true,
that Anthony Mackie,
who's Falcon --
-Oh, he's great.
-He's the most fun human being.
We love Anthony Mackie.
We've had him on our show
since "Late Night,"
and I heard that you and him
are getting a spin-off --
You're getting a series
on Disney+.
-That's the word, yeah.
It only took
about four press tours
for somebody to kind of
get the idea
that these two lunatics
should have a show, you know?
-Yeah.
So the rumors are true?
-The rumors are --
The rumors are true.
Yeah.
-I didn't even believe that.
You're doing it so well.
-No, they are.
I mean, I love him because,
like, it's really hard.
Like, I always quote "Apollo 13"
every time I'm with him
because, it's, like,
working with him
is really like riding
a psychotic horse
in a blazing stable.
Like, that's what it is.
I just hang on.
And usually
if you look at my expressions,
like, just get a word in now.
-I have a clip here from a press
junket that you guys were doing.
Can you explain
what he kept doing?
'Cause it's ridiculous.
-Right.
-The name?
-Yeah, he -- So, you know,
like, we do this a lot.
I mean, you're in there
for, you know, three,
four days at a time.
-Days of the same questions?
-Yeah, the same questions, and
you can't really spoil anything.
You can't talk about the movie.
So after a while, we kind of
start having fun with it.
And he and I sort of, like,
invented this character
that we sort of, kind of,
came up with.
So that any time they would ask
us a serious question,
like, you know, especially
in the European pressers,
like,
"How do you feel this movie
is really going to
change the world?"
And we're like,
"Well, as my friend...
-Is it Nishka?
-...Ishtata used to say..."
-And so you'd just
make up a name?
-Yeah, and then we're like --
We'd say something obscure
like, "When you look
in the mirror, make sure
you look in the back
and the front at the same time."
"That's what my friend..."
-And they're like, "Right."
"I wouldn't say it,
but that's what --
My friend Ishna would say that."
I have a clip, kind of
a compilation of you playing.
It's so funny.
Here are Sebastian
and Anthony Mackie
doing press for
"Captain America: Civil War."
Take a look at this.
-As my friend Nish would say,
always enjoy the pants you're in
because you never know
what's in another man's pants.
-That's right.
-As my friend Nishka would say,
I ain't saying
I'm a gold digger, but I am.
-But he rich.
-I think when you have
two beautiful people
and you put them together,
there's nothing bad
that can come out of that.
-What a lovely last answer.
-That's not me.
-Thank you so much.
-That's Nishka.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm looking forward to more
goof-offs with you and Anthony.
We love you. Sebastian Stan!